foreign
back to Texas to my hometown in h-tone
and let's talk to Katie Katie what's up
hey Dr John how are you
I'm still recovering from being in Texas
this last few days
what have you all done I I'm still
wondering not myself yeah it's a steam
room that you can't escape from that's a
great way to say that and then when you
get your car and the air conditioner is
on you're just all wet
yeah exactly I mean you can walk to your
mailbox and be drenched in sweat it's
ridiculous
jeez
plus who still gets mail all right so
what's up how can I help
that would have been way funnier if it
was m-a-l-e Box by the way that'd been
hilarious I don't even know what that
that's a great place for like a like a
like like male dancers it should be
called the mailbox and it's just m-a-l-e
I think would that be funny Kelly no I
would imagine somebody's already come up
with that somewhere or the mail room am
I Ellie I don't know I think they'll be
hilarious all right Katie what's up
um okay I'm gonna try my very best to
make it a very poignant question
um but basically
I entered into
an affair with a married man a couple
years ago and it's been off and on
and A lot's happened but what I my
question is
is how do I handle
the loneliness of ending it
um that I'm going to feel
and how do I go about my day-to-day with
my job being around family and friends
and having this heavy weight
that I'm carrying and ending a
relationship with someone that I've been
very deeply attached to for
many many years
So when you say a lot happened thank you
number one think of your question you
asked that perfect
um when you say a lot happened there's a
lot in that sentence what do you mean
unpack that for me
as we were co-workers this goes
back um and
and we you know he was married and so
and I wasn't attracted to him at all and
I had never been in a relationship
before I started dating very late in
life I've always cut my guard up against
guys
um and so I've always had this wall up
but he came along and
slowly you know started kind of breaking
those walls down
um it would start with just banter about
work related things non-work related
things in the office and and we kind of
became friends and
so it became an emotional affair long
before it became a physical one
um and so about six years in
um
I could sense that he was attracted to
me
um but he knew that I I was you know
very inexperienced and you know I had
never really dated anybody but there was
always this flirtation going on and um
and then one day he asked me Point Blank
if I had feelings for him because he had
feelings for me
so we had a very long discussion and I
said yes I do but I there's nothing that
we can do about it because you're
married
and um
so a couple months go by and I'm it's
like this big elephant in the room now
we can't be the same around each other
and
and I start to feel this very strong
desire to to let this in because he's
saying that he loves me and I had never
heard that before so it just starts to
feel very good and I
decided to be with him
um physically and so
I lost my virginity to him and
a month later I found out that I was
pregnant
and um
and I knew sorry you're okay take a take
a breath it's hard this probably is not
a story you just openly share all the
time right no it's not
no thank you for thank you for honoring
me with your trust
take your time thank you
um
anyway
I knew
before I even told him that I was
pregnant I I knew that he was going to
want me to have an abortion which was
difficult for me
but I started to feel very guilty
um
for you know if I keep it and what that
would do to him and his family
and um because I was very good about
just kind of keeping this bubble that we
were in
um and you know I told him look I know
like I don't expect you to ever leave
her for me I know you made a commitment
like I'm fine with just keeping this
just the way it is with us we'll just
keep it in this little box
um and then when I got pregnant you know
everything changed and you know he
not in so many words but I could tell he
was very much wanting me to get an
abortion and so
I decided to just gut it up and do it
and
um the aftermath of that was very
painful
um
and so I can tell by by the by just how
you're talking about it is it still
painful
yeah and shame
and
um and so he gave that to me and then
you know several months go by and
I feel very lonely and very confused and
so
um I let him back in and
so we
resumed the affair and his wife his wife
has no idea this has been going on
and he said
yes I think she knows that I'm having an
affair but she won't ask about it
and that took me by surprise and I said
why and he was like
because then we would have to deal with
it
um you know just
like keep that wall up kind of thing so
let me just let me hop in here so
why now why end this
why have you reached the end here
because you've been through a lot of
what I would consider like roadblocks
and you've chosen to go around them and
go around them and go around them and go
around them why now
because I'm getting older and I see
everyone around me all my friends you
know settling down in life you know
getting married and having babies and
I'm you know
letting myself be in this situation
where it's a dead end and
um and I know it is and I know that it
it needs to end permanently because I've
I've ended it
like I said it's been on and off over
the over a few years and
I have moments where I'm very strong and
I'm like I can handle this I can you
know we can move on from each other and
it's fine but then I hit these very low
low moments and
surely surely those moments include
losing that dream of being a mom even
though that wasn't a dream you thought
you had surely those moments
are
you know deep down this whole thing ends
in Ash and you've known from day one
yeah there is there there cannot be a
happy ending here
yeah
like do you have any sort of remorse or
guilt for the like imagine being on the
other side of this
and if you don't if you don't say yeah I
know not really yeah you mean like being
being like in his wife's shoes you mean
yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah
justifying in my head
um
you know I would never I don't have
anything against her I don't want to
ruin her life you have
that's that's that's a foregone
conclusion
you and him together have
well he's had
more context he's had
for me and
um whether you're one or many or one of
it doesn't matter
like I mean you can do what you can to
do some mental gymnastics to distance
yourself from it but her life is ruined
the problem is right now it's being
ruined like Sands of an hourglass she's
slowly suffocating in her own home
um
because she's married to somebody with
so little Integrity it's just staggering
to me he doesn't even have integrity
about his lack of Integrity right he
doesn't even say like I'm leaving you
because I no longer want to
be with you I want to be with somebody
else or I no longer want to be tied down
he doesn't even have integrity about
what a scumbag he is
but
I here's the only way through this is
right through it
and I think what you're trying to do is
trying to figure out a path out of this
Mass
that doesn't involve pain and that path
does not exist
and so
um
you have to
choose
I'm gonna I've I have violated my own
core sense of humanity and I did it in
the name of
love and I did it in the name of I just
put my guard down
and that's not the person I want to be
anymore that's not who I am and I know
this ends awfully and so you walk right
through that and you get a couple of
your friends and you enter into a season
of grief man because you lose somebody
that you actually do care about and you
lose somebody who yeah you got pregnant
with and you lose somebody that you fell
in love with that you know deep down is
a terrible person that you could never
be with even if he left his wife and
said I'm with you forever you know you
couldn't be with him because he'd turn
around and have somebody else within the
next year
and so
the only way through it is to go through
the grief of that and I think your grief
is going to be multi-layered you're
going to have the loneliness but behind
or underneath that loneliness of missing
a guy who's probably a great lover and
he's probably funny and he knows you and
he has the Work Connection and the
intimate connection all that
beneath that
is this
like you walled yourself off from the
world to avoid this exact moment I'm
gonna stay away from men because men are
bad news and they are going to make me
violate my own core values and I'm going
to end up in places I don't want to be
and here you are
and to me that is going to be the
hardest thing you have to grieve
because everything you spent all of your
life trying to avoid has has come to
your front door and you open the door
and let it in
does that make sense
yeah I know 100 it does
so if I'm you I'm just gonna be I would
quit my job
I'd quit my job I would get so far away
because I don't want to work at a place
where that guy is either
well we don't work together anymore
um so there is
even more space
um
but yeah in a way it intensified the the
longing
between us I think
you just gotta know Katie it's not real
yeah it's not real your hurt is
but this affair is not real
um
have you told any of your friends
I opened up
one of my best friends right after I
found out I was pregnant that's when I
told her everything
um
and but she doesn't know that I went
back to him and that's another thing is
I've been utterly terrified
telling her that
it's been
years
um
of keeping it from Earth
because she was really there for me when
I you know had the abortion and um you
know gave me a lot of support
um but I've been afraid to let her down
you have
she just doesn't know it yet
and so the only way back through that is
to sit down with your friend that you
love and trust and say
I'm gonna break your heart because I've
broken my own
and I need some help
the definition of addiction is a
compulsive behavior that you continue to
do even after your body has identified
it's bad for you
so this isn't technically an addiction
if you will like in the classic
chemically sense substance abuse kind of
way
um
but Pia Melody one of the great authors
talks about something called love
addiction this idea that I cannot I
can't walk away from something that I
know is going to kill me it's it's it's
actively killing me the secrets the
disgust I feel when I look in the mirror
the disgust when I'm driving home and
he's going home to his wife and his kids
this other imaginary life he has and I'm
going home alone
and then you keep going back even even
though you know and you know and you
know so I tell you that to tell you you
can't do this by yourself
you can't do this by yourself
you're gonna have to reach out to a
friend that you care and risk that
friend saying I don't want to be friends
with somebody who would do that
or maybe she opens her arms up really
big and says this ends today but I'll
walk with you
and my guess is untangling all these
emotions and all these years and all of
the secrecy and all the times you've had
to not be honest with your other
co-workers and your friends and your
family
going through an abortion alone
all of it
that panic when those times over the
last few years when you think his wife
is calling you or emailing you or
figured something all of that you're
gonna have to get somebody to untangle
that with you
and then ultimately you have to get to a
place where you forgive Katie and then
you make a covenant with yourself that
that never happens again that you honor
Katie enough
to never
get involved this way systematically
again
and I hope you hear my voice I'm with
you
I'm sad for you
I am
but I'm with you
and I'm not gonna sit here and beat you
up
and everybody listening
from your little keyboards throwing
grenades on this situation is not going
to help it is what it is it's already
burned to the ground
there's just a couple of survivors
staggering around
I think this ends today
I think you commit to yourself and to
him and to everybody around you it's the
last time we speak this last time I
talked to you I block you on everything
I drop everything you are out of my life
and for good you might have to move
Apartments you might have to do all quit
your job I don't care what you have to
do
you are going to drown in this
this is the moment when the alcoholic
takes all the bottles and pours them
down the sink you gotta walk away
and then you gotta look around at the
burn down landscape of your life and say
when people help me rebuild this thing
can be rebuilt 100 percent
but the lying and the deception and the
secrets and the
just utter violation over years
of your own Integrity of your this
person's poor wife and kids all of it
stops today
and I'll be with you every step of the
way Katie call anytime I'm not going to
hate on you your life's hard hard enough
already I'll sit with you to figure out
what to do next
please call your friend today